you know what it's something that i do
have in my character very strongly
is my love of women and when i hear
you talk about katy perry
i just i marveled i really like you know
sometimes
like you know with balance and wellness
i'm like i am trying i'm hanging on i'm
like the cat like hang in there i'm
doing my best
you know i think you're so dope and rad
and your messaging and energy that you
send out
to your whole entire family is so
positive and it's such an amazing
example of how
we all can create that narrative and
behave that way and set a tone for
everybody
so that thank you thank you
i adore katie and i just feel so happy
that
orlando has found someone that makes his
heart so happy
because at the end of the day for flynn
to have a happy father and a happy
mother
it's just the most important thing so
i'm just so grateful
that orlando and katie found each other
and i'm so grateful that i found my
incredible husband and just that we
all really respect each other and when
it comes to
you know special occasions when we have
to be together
um we work it out so we have compromises
that we work out together
for like what is the best for our whole
family
but we really do always think of what is
the best thing for flynn
and i just think that that's the most
important thing
at the end of the day i couldn't agree
more i put my north star my compass
always to my children first and life
always falls into the right place if i
do that
and i i just i love
like like my heart is like swelling
and swooning and i just i love that
and i have nothing but respect and just
like
let us all treat each other this way and
and be these people and i just i love it
i
dig you big time miranda i think you're
rad and
i love your whole line there's a reason
it's a cult favorite and
so successful and everywhere and i just
thank you so much for your time today
and i really loved your story about your
grandparents
and i will be as that my head hits the
pillow tonight
thinking about your grandfather bringing
home these crystals and these rocks to
your grandmother
you know my grandma she's the one that
really taught me that generosity of
spirit the generosity of your heart
and that and just being kind is the most
gracious thing that you can do and
treating everyone
with that kindness be sure to order your
cora organics today skin care is a great
gift
for the holidays and so much more